ian pognati is walking into probably his
last over the board tournament before
the world championship match
very likely very likely because there is
not such a big choice of for the
tournaments and
some of them are
you know basically not interesting
enough he played two matches against
world champion mangus carlson in norway
chess both ended in draw but nepomniacci
lost
in armageddon two
relatively quick draws but i guess
because games were more or less fine but
i don't think it
really matters
what matters now is the world
championship but he does not want to
talk about his preparations did you get
some answers today
well uh
even if i
get them even if i got some answers i
would never tell about it have you
gathered a team
well it's
i i believe this is sort of a secret so
what's the plan now for you leading up
to the world championship match well i
just continue my preparation so the
fight is simple and then i play the
image
[Music]
you were in new york in 2016 and some
people were saying maybe you were
working with karakin somehow but will
you be talking to him before the match
to get some advice
well why not i think if it would be
useful then okay for of course i will
talk to him but
uh actually i just was in new york as a
guest so
just
uh was very
very interesting you know to
basically hang around he had to feel the
atmosphere of the match and
of course it's
very special chess event here you know
it's
you know you can't attend it every day
magnus carlsen has held the throne for
eight years how are you feeling about
the match of course i'm
excited and i'm really
i'm really looking forward and it's
really challenging how will you beat
magnus in the match
just wait for a couple of months